provence 1er février 54 un homme lançait
un appel à la subversion plus
précisément à l'insurrection de la bonté
il parlait sur radio luxembourg
on pouvait penser que le siècle des
progrès les rendre 40 ans plus tard cet
appel inutiles ou même des uv ce n'est
pas le cas l'abbé pierre est toujours
révolté reportage de marc maisonneuve et
eric de lannion l'hiver 1954 il y à
presque 40 ans jour pour jour
l'appel lancé par l'abbé pierre est un
véritable appel au secours
et pendant ce temps que fait nuit il y à
des peurs et des femmes et
petits-enfants qui ont préparé les
voyons toutes les nuits pour détendue
dans la neige sur le toit
quarante ans plus tard sentent millions
de français sont mal logées dit l'abbé
pierre
heitz ville il retrouve ce matin deux de
ses anciens compagnons de l'hiver 54
il avait 20 ans alors ensemble quand ils
évoquent leurs souvenirs il parle d'un
probant l'idée avant tout par la
lassitude de la mort vive ce qui n'avait
pas vécu le moment 18 es trop jeune il
le il pensait se souvenir comme une fête
je me suis dit me fâcher pour leur dire
c'est pas acceptable d'en faire un
souvenir de fait c'est un souvenir de
deug comme nous qui l'avons vécu et de
deuil
encore aujourd'hui par seulement de
deuil à 40 ans mais encore aujourd'hui
l'autre souvenir qui demeure pour les
compagnons c'est l'immense élan de
solidarité provoquées par ces tables et
qui ressemble si peu un curé
traditionnel challenge
des buts il valait les premiers ont
sauvé des check points ont été obligés
de mettre un bébé noir
je viens d'écouter ce qu'avait dit aux
médias et mansaly ou med 7,1 alors là
dit pauvre ben laden une baignoire le
matage alors évident à 81 ans l'abbé
pierre le défenseur des sans abri de
ceux qui n'ont plus guère que lui pour
croire que l'espoir existe à bercy je
cite que l'on n'attende pas de moi que
je reste tranquille